Venezuela was once a thriving prosperous
country but under socialist leaders like
coogo Chavez and now Nicolas Maduro
the government seizure of companies
meant that when their main resource oil
saw volatility well the economy
collapsed now nearly nine and ten
Venezuelans live in poverty a food is so
scarce reports say that some have been
forced to eat pigeons and cats they find
in the street now Maduro has only
tightened its grip
imprisoning political opponents and all
of this leading to violent clashes and
the global community including the US
has lined up behind opposition leader
Hwang Guido now despite all that
congresswoman Ilan Omar is well you
guessed it blaming us a lot of the
policies that we've put in place has
kind of helped lead the devastation in
Venezuela and we've sort of set the
stage for where we were arriving today
this particular bullying and the use of
sanctions here now Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo mr. secretary thank you for
being with us tonight now when you hear
a member of the House of Representatives
put the blame squarely on the quote
bullies in the United States
what's we're saying tonight and
Venezuela what's your reaction so the
nice thing I could say is it's
unbelievable ignorance it's just
factually wrong you you hit it in your
opening Laura the problems in Venezuela
have been years in the making it's been
a socialist regime first with Chavez now
with Maduro the destruction of a nut
wait wealthy nation the nation with more
oil reserves than any other country in
the world beautiful content a beautiful
country with beautiful real estate
beautiful shorelines all kinds of
opportunity for a member of Congress who
frankly one who sits on an important
national security committee to make a
statement blaming America first in this
way it's not only ignorant it's
disgusting what can you tell us tonight
still not a successful transition in
Venezuela guido was the guy that the
community the world community chose why
is he the right one at the right time so
the world community is certainly
supported but the Venezuelan people
chose him through their gnash
assembly and through their
constitutional process the military
didn't fracture in the way that we would
hope but it's just a matter of time it's
it's the case that Maduro may rule for a
little while longer but he's not going
to govern structurally there's no way he
stays in power it's time for him to
leave and we need the Cubans in the
rushes to follow him out the door now to
Americans who say look we have a problem
in our southern border we got a hundred
thousand people a month being
apprehended and released into the
country why are we focusing at all on
Venezuela what do you say to them so we
can do more than one thing at a time we
have an obligation to secure our
southern border but we've had three
million people three million migrants
leave Venezuela - they will end up
somewhere today they're in Colombia
Chile Peru we have an important
responsibility in Venezuela first we
want to support democracy in South
America it's important for our vital
national security interests but it's
also the case when we see humanitarian
crises like this the American people
understand the taking food and providing
humanitarian support is something that's
in our nature I want to move on to
another topic which is China something
that you've been addressing lately I've
been talking about this for 20 years but
Joe Biden doesn't seem to think China is
a big threat let's watch China is going
to eat our lunch come on man
they can't even figure out how to deal
with the the fact that they have this
great division between the China Sea and
the mountains in the East I mean in the
West I mean I you know they're not bad
folks folks but guess what they're not a
competition for us I don't even know I
don't personally know what to say about
that but China not a threat to the
United States what is the truth there
President Trump and our administration
has taken the threat from China very
very seriously very different from what
we just heard there they want he's in
he's leading in the polls we understand
the threat there there's a trade
imbalance that President Trump has taken
on to try and get fair and reciprocal
trade between the United States and
China the fact that the Chinese are
working to put their systems in networks
all across the world so they could steal
your information to my information how
about American
and American universities to feed this
information back into their system
you've talked about this we've talked
about a million of their ethnic
minorities being held in reeducation
champs and zhang singh that this is this
is stuff that is reminiscent of the
1930s they present a real challenge to
the United States and this
administration is prepared to take this
on American high tech companies in China
is a lot of concern that there has been
I guess inadvertent assistance to the
communist regime there as they seek to
dominate part of their belton Road
initiative dominate every major industry
including space and weaponry artificial
intelligence what can you tell us about
the concerns about American big tech
going to China setting up shop we've
talked about this and we've gone out to
talk to each of these businesses Lori
it's true I think America was slow to
recognize this challenge the previous
administration the Obama administration
just didn't want to touch it the first
step is to make these businesses aware
this is what the technology is being
used for here's how you're selling it to
the separation between private companies
and government doesn't exist they're not
remotely like we have in the United
States and so we've made clear to them
that their technology's been used in
ways that they may not be aware of and
the impact not only impact it has for
American national security but the
impact it will have on their business
and the business's reputation is very
real i mr. secretary I also want to get
your reaction to something one of your
predecessors said last night on MSNBC
watch why should Russia have all the fun
and since Russia is clearly backing
Republicans why don't we ask China to
back us not only that China if you're
listening why don't you get Trump's tax
returns let's have a great power contest
and let's get the Chinese in on the side
of somebody else leading Democrat shoes
on for an hour last night the great
power contest asking China dump the tax
returns so there is a great power
contest taking place I think that's true
I only wish when she was Secretary of
State she would have taken it on instead
of allowing it to get where it is today
and turning a willful blind eye to that
we're taking this seriously I had
those comments before they don't
remotely sound like what what ought to
be done by America and they're certainly
not what President Trump in this
administration going to do to make sure
we keep America safe that we recognize
China is a 1.5 billion people there will
be commerce between the two countries
but we've got to make sure that America
is prepared so that we can continue to
be the world's leading power 10 20 50
years from now are you having more fun
now than you were as CIA director I was
thinking about that if I could choose
between one or the other like what's
much what's more fun they're very
different jobs
I've enjoyed them both really appreciate
it